le 16 avril le centre ville de
beauceville était complètement inondée
après une débâcle
parmi les 54 entreprises fortement
touchés le restaurant normandie sur le
boulevard renault en plus de l'eau le
restaurant a subi une explosion de gaz
un mois plus tard les dommages sont
toujours considérables le bâtiment est
une perte totale
j'ai pas die les restaurants 80's savoie
un groupe r king ne suis personne nous
aident maquis fortin croyait pouvoir
bénéficier du programme général
d'indemnisation pour les entreprises
lors de sinistres
mais depuis 2010 est un critère établi
une limite de 2 millions de dollars de
revenus bruts ou de chiffre d'affaires
pour y être admissible un indicateur bsd
estime monsieur fortin super 550000 de
salaire 500000 nourriture et que ces
travaux de fournitures les restaurateurs
ils servent comme il faut travailler
pour une petite un petit bénéfice à
hambourg c'est un représente absolument
rien de ton pouvoir de rembourser
quelque chose selon tes bénéfice net a
pas de sens plusieurs stations service
sont dans la même situation
ces capsules dit on fait moins les
employés - hydro-québec - tout irait
sérieux c'est quoi des 1000 dollars
alors là on est en irak des cent mille
dollars l'autre il faut lui tout
arracher on fait tout en notre possible
pour ouvrir loi en espérant que les
deviennent enquête parle
est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin les
villes de beauceville et de sainte-marie
demande à la ministre de la sécurité
publique de revoir ses critères
il ya plusieurs commerces qui sont
encore fermés contenus qui sont toujours
en attente de réponse du gouvernement
provincial
la ministre geneviève guilbaud souligne
que le programme de la sécurité publique
est une aide de dernier recours
il existe d'autres programmes
disponibles au ministère de l'économie
donc j'invite les entrepreneurs qui ont
des questions ou en tout cas veulent
vérifier la possibilité de recevoir de
l'aide a contacté le ministère de
l'économie de l'innovation
le ministère de l'économie répond de son
côté qu'il accompagne les entreprises
touchés à travers ses programmes
réguliers mais qu'ils ne disposent pas
de programme d'urgence particulier en
cas d'inondation les commerçants
sinistre
j'espère que les démarches de leurs élus
municipaux portent fruit c'est très très
dur à vivre c'est un super beau de ma
vie ici nayla bendali radio-canada
beauceville